ma la vita di casa e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video non era proprio spagnolo
chissenefrega
a proposito non c'entra un cazzo
spagnolo perché siamo su troy bayliss
quest perché mi hanno fatto un altro
ancora chiusa adventure ragazzi questo
io non l'ho mai fatto ovviamente anche
gli altri però degli altri ogni tanto
c'era qualche li bellino che negli
scorsi avevano già messo quindi capitava
questo proprio non l'ho mai non sapevo
neanche della sua esistenza
vabbè proviamo e vediamo cosa succede
let's go allora marilyn quanti si alza
la gonna ovviamente come nei classici
film sembra anche fatto molto meglio
perché è uscito molto dopo questo
rispetto agli altri non ho idea di che
cosa io debba fare problemi il livello è
disegnato da dio cioè dei tuoi di tudin
riferisco a scorso il più bello dove
disegnato forse deve ottenere no
a farci google non pensavo proprio a
questo la fa niente
ovvio o questo è un classico film
ragazzini mary linguaggi se non avete
visti marilyn monroe faceva con le
tartarughine voi non lo sapete b
istruisco io si è scoperto dopo tutto
sto casino che in realtà quello che
soffiava da soltanto pino era quello
delle tartarughe ninja fantastico
perfetto ragazzi presentazione di iphone
13 ai 13 scusatemi e donald trump del
fantastico devo forse c'è lo zaino top
secret la chiedilo subito a posto next
level ragazzino bravo nel sole americana
quanto pare ecco qua morgan vvv se non è
morgan cioè non è possibile proviamo
usare un intendiamo da succede
devo cliccare su di lui ma è ho cliccato
il naso prima avete dato che schifo
la cosa più orribile vi abbia mai vi
basta finisce livello allora i click
grazie nov
ho già mangiato grazie gentilissimo
diamanti è ubicato sul naso buttato un
aiuto ma cacchio troll album cristiano
ronaldo mi manca comunque è tira la sua
traversa
la tira ma tanto cosa c'entra con
l'america cristiano ronaldo niente non
c'entra niente con l'america come lei
usa adventure e juventus adventure
ragazzi mi sa che qua devo usare un
aiuto perché non ho idea di che cosa
debba fare ho cliccato sulla palla
secondo me devo schiacciare qualcosa in
giro che non vedo tipo la traversa tipo
qualcos'altro
la palla a devo tener premuto sulla
palla che io sto usando tutti gli aiuti
ragazzi palla da rugby
vai perfetta ragazzi ne rosati 2 di
aiuti solo per ronaldo quindi visto già
perdendo tutti davanti a posto
li sto già per me ne mancano solo due
quindi vediamo di tenerli allora questo
è perfetto ottimo bel atterraggio allora
vedi atterrare meglio
non ho capito che era chiarissimo era la
tesla non facciamoci domande però va beh
quando hanno mandato la macchina e lo
spazio era quello il discorso la space
hicks andiamo avanti ragazzi non mask fa
niente c'è un perfetto dunque tutti
rappresentati alla perfezione se avrai
tempo pietro lui può entrare permesso
non si apre lisciati addosso che ti devo
patena ma non c entri lì lo sci entry
anche devo anche volendo deve uscire
qualcuno no da che questa difficile
perché non capisco cosa devo fare
tirati un pugno da solo in faccia
fortissimo eccolo carone maledetto come
ti permetti di cagare a central park e
toy di ipad o una roba si sfonderebbe in
tempo zero
chissà che cagata ha fatto che la
madonna sono io dopo il cenone di natale
di mia nonna bellissimo tro il face
league
lorenzo vede a cagare anche se ogni
tanto si parla sempre di quello in
trofei queste scorregge kakà pupo è cosa
che fanno ridere i bimbi cosa facciamo
io non ho capito niente ma va bene
questo non è anche fallito una volta
questo
fa capire quanto il mio cervello ormai
sia traviato da sto gioco
michael jackson credo sia michael geloso
e michael jackson certo c'è una merda
michael no michael hai pestato una merda
adesso fai un work dai bravo l'ha fatta
davvero
ormai sono le cose sono le cose ancora
prima che succedano failed cioè la fa
memoria salsa di michael eccolo bravo
michael lo completato dove andare
veramente chissà come si falliva a
livello di michael bo la m troll
wickmayer
va bene e quindi è morto niente livello
fallita santo iddio e ai vero ragazzi
c'era un sacco di foto che avevano tipo
seviziato un leone per forza robben poi
alla fine sono foto fake prove a la
metto dietro a quel culo così e la m
cool e mayer si parla sempre di quello
tutta la freschezza non scappiamo da lì
tranquilli o il monte rushmore non l'ho
mai visto ok tipo l'attacco di giganti
sin dentro la roccia ci sono i conti a
posto sarà brava papà meraviglioso
siamo all'ultimo ho ancora 2 2 cose due
aiuti programma non farlo senza aiuti
vediamo quest'anno a questa incrimina
c'è forse lo dedotto dal dal bicchiere
per riesco a tirare sulla bozza oggi la
bottiglia o all'infuori di glutei ok
perfetto
sto facendo è volata ma come però venire
per cosa è riuscito a fare cose che ho
fatto
no ma inneggia al cacchio lo avevo fatto
qualcosa non so cosa sulla bottiglia
ok nel bicchiere lavori nel bicchiere
oppure nel deretano
ok a decolli proprio in aria vai
ok perfetto si ricollega questa proprio
una storia una trama bellissimo nicki
minaj che vola perfetto credo se non ho
capito se l'ascoli non è di china gigi
però vabbè non ho finito xvii e l'ultimo
donald trump bellissimo donante grazie
mille di esistere
vediamo se riusciamo a fare qualcosa di
decente alla casa bianca si è nascosto
sei una pannocchia è l'esatto colore
della fascia di donald trump
quindi ecco qua quindi valle fallito era
meglio come presidente dottor resto
ovviamente e proviamo a cambiare anche
donald vedremo se ci vediamo se c'è
qualcun altro non è che nessun altro se
non va
ok questo secondo me non riesco neanche
con gli aiuti ragazzi perché è un
livello opus a più tentativi ok quindi
sappiamo solo che deve uscire donald
alla fine ma non solo devono fare con
lui non ho idea se voi cosa devo fare
con lui sicuro quindi prima lo faccio
uscire poi accade qualcosa da zucchi
troppo porco demonio sbagliato a noi
deve uscire tra un pò che non deve non
deve uscire da un'altra meno male che ho
che ho risparmiato gli aiuti devo far
uscire qualcun altro dalla finestra
mannaggia il kawasaki a non ne ho idea
certo telefono è muto forse a suonava
l'altro telefono che hai rispondi quello
e kin jong no veramente non so neanche
cosa dire no no
[Musica]